[Applause]
foreign
yes
happy Friday and I am wearing green you
just can't see it
it's inside me all right let's welcome
tonight's guest he's a comedian who owns
a razor company which makes him a real
cut up ah
westernrazor.com owner David Angelo
he was into red hat way before it was
cool founder of the Guardian Angels
Curtis Sliwa
she doesn't need x-ray vision to see
through your BS co-hosts have
outnumbered in former White House Press
Secretary Kaylee mcenany
and finally if you're a fan of big
government prepare for an argument Fox
News contributor captive
all right as you know it's Friday so
before we get to some new stories we're
gonna do this
Greg's leftovers
hmm yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck I get to kill a writer
here we go during Wednesday's episode of
The View host a Whoopi Goldberg appeared
to audibly pass gas
critics are calling it the most
intelligent thing she's ever said
the Pentagon is blaming a Russian
fighter jet for causing a U.S drone to
crash into the Black Sea
and now officials worry the Russians
plan to hide the wreckage by leaving it
at a laptop repair shop
Heinz at New York Fourth Graders saw
test scores plummet during the coveted
lockdowns on the bright side teachers
say students are now stabbing at a sixth
grade level
that's funny violent kids make me laugh
new data from the FDA shows the pills
most likely to be smuggled into the
United States are generic Viagra
investigators were tipped off when the
drug sniffing dogs humped their legs for
six hours
[Laughter]
oh remember her actress Lindsay Lohan
has announced she's pregnant with her
first child
and you can tell the kid takes after her
since the ultrasound came back as mug
shots
[Laughter]
pork thing
a former California teacher of the year
has been arraigned on charges that she
had sex with a 13 year old boy or his
friends call him student of the year
yeah
anyway New Jersey environmental
officials they have New Jersey
environmental officials have you been to
New Jersey anyway
they have cleared 21 Acres of forest to
create a better habitat for the
endangered American Woodcock bird
they also hope to breed it with a
European crested tit
to create a bird with the sexiest name
ever
[Applause]
till you're blue in the face
I just might
Khloe Kardashian was called out this
week for posting unrealistic
photoshopped pictures on Instagram and
rightfully so if you look closely in the
background you could see a book
[Music]
I bet she reads
the
it's making a cruel joke that I decided
not to do what's wrong with me all right
for St Patrick's Day today former New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo wore a Kiss
Me I'm Irish button
on his pants
[Music]
that that's funny because you couldn't
get away with that now
and today of course was the big St
Patrick's Day Parade here in New York
City here's how it breaks down in March
the parade makes a mess of Fifth Avenue
then in June the Gay Pride Parade tidies
it up
[Laughter]
the British prison made headlines this
week after it was revealed that female
guards have been having sex with male
inmates upon hearing this story David
Angelo has decided to move to England
and rob a bank
rather
than
just date just commit a crime I mean you
know marriage is a prison so
you end up there one way or another
there you go all right let's get to the
stories uh disturbing story still
lingers did Ron eat pudding with his
fingers and how did the Florida gov lose
those handles of love
former Governor Ron DeSantis is fueling
speculation he's lost a lot of weight
slimming down ahead of a presidential
run folks are noticing a leaner meaner
gov on his recent trips and we put this
graphic together because all the weight
loss stories need a handy dandy before
and after so this is the before right
there what we would call husky bordering
on Jolly right
those were the words we used when I was
young oh he's jolly now here's the after
oh my goodness that is amazing actually
this is him now I mean I guess so he
does look slimmer so is this the
proverbial sign like it was for other
candidates who lost weight before a run
like Mike Huckabee or Chris Christie or
even William Howard Taft
yes you thought Taft was Hefty in office
but this is how fat Taft was before he
ran for office
I remember that picture
a Guinness book but really how did Ron
slim down some think he might be on
ozempic the trendy diabetes drug that
celebrities are using to get thin quick
but like what David Angelo actually does
for a living it's all speculation
[Laughter]
that's with Ron's weight too and his old
eating habits they report that in 2019
on a private jet he ate chocolate
pudding with three of his fingers now we
don't know which three fingers so we
sent a staffer to learn more thanks Greg
we actually caught up with a pudding
expert on his lunch break that's right
Gene I love this stuff I can't get
enough of it so Joe tell us how do you
eat pudding with just three fingers
honestly my hands are a little dirty
right now can I demonstrate by showing
you uh okay
oh so oh
[Music]
so weird
it's so weird was it a coincidence that
Joe Mackey had pitched this story
no one else is covering this uh but but
we are and then he does that all right
uh David uh do we put in with your hands
I use a spoon Greg I'm a little more
civilized yes yes does this discount him
from running if you're going to look at
can you look at him now like that
remember the lady that ate a salad with
her comb what's her name Amy Klobuchar
the only thing I know about her yeah
that's that you get stained by these
things David like being a Razer salesman
yeah it's true I'm a one-issue voter and
it's pudding cups
this is definitely going to turn me off
to Ron
but it's nice to see him losing some
weight doing some stuff just you know
body image it's the one you know it's
it's you're not really supposed to say
things about people's body anymore but
it a republican politician it's fair
game yeah and that's like the nice thing
it's like with Trump you know his hair
his face
sessions it's like look at that little
elf yeah but then all the rest of the
time like you guys we can't talk about
it yes yes exactly that's not nice yeah
how would you describe your body type
fantastic I mean look at me
all right perfect
I guess that's why they call you a
comedian because that was a joke
all right Curtis uh do you think
DeSantis is running and do you think he
has a shot with Trump looming in the
darkness waiting to pounce
you know you mentioned Gutfeld Shamu El
Jefe Chris Christie right man was he you
Pompeo
hey what the hell happened to you Mike
yeah what were you a bulimic and then
can we ever forget how Slim Shady
Sharpton yes he looks like a bobble head
dog yeah he turns around that's because
his head doesn't shrink but his body did
well let me tell you something the
scientist your man's man three fingers
Finger Licking Good do you eat that KFC
original out of the bucket I mean that's
some man's man
dipping you gave me an idea dipping a
drumstick and pudding oh think about
that ah yeah that's a combo you don't
see very often all right Kaylee we have
you on for these deep political stories
so let's dig into the pudding story you
were you you had to deal with a lot of
fake news oh that's fake news yeah do I
watch it no do you think it's fake news
that he had the pudding yeah I I do um
here's why it's really funny to watch
the press and their obsession with
Republicans and food you know let the
left has gotten precisely one headline
about food and it's the one you
mentioned yeah salad fiend Amy Klobuchar
once berated an aid for forgetting a
fork but when it's Republicans my former
boss president Trump everyone loved to
talk about his affinity for McDonald's
and fast food just this week there was
reporting he had KFC on board Trump
Force One yes and then you look over to
DeSantis and they say their problems
with him are that he eats in front of
him people at meetings okay what's the
problem there that he goes to places
where there are cupcakes if there's a
cupcake in a meeting on Capitol Hill he
would have gone to that place I would
have done that at Fox hey cupcakes well
you guys never have cupcakes over at
Gutfeld no no maybe the Jesse Waters
team I'd go over it cupcakes when
they're not whistling or singing they're
not whistling or singing um and then
this about the pudding I I mean what is
it with the Press just leave the eating
habits alone there's so much else you
guys go after but the eating habits they
just can't give it up here's a bigger
issue about the concern about about diet
is why does it matter if somebody's
using ozempic yeah it's if it actually
works right and like if you drop 10 to
20 of your body weight that lengthens
your lifespan so even it even outweighs
no pun intended that's comedy David
uh no uh yes yes yes
um that actually outweighs the side
effects like if those epic has a side
effect but it causes you to lose you
know 20 of your body weight could be
like 40 pounds that's like a big deal
I'm not by the way on the payroll of
ozempa it was epic but I could be yes
always practice my selling points
don't you know didn't they ever tell you
TV puts 10 pounds on your chubby cheeks
right yeah yeah I sat there with Rudy
Giuliani when he ran for mayor and he
was having a slice right a slice of
pizza his campaign manager a guy named
David took it right out of his mouth
like he was a Mama Luke said you need to
lose 10 pounds because you're 10 pounds
fat on TV weight loss you're not going
to Iowa weight loss you go to Iowa
you're running for president oh corn
dogs everything's coined and you wash it
down with ethanol oh man I would love it
I would love a corn dog shake cat do you
think it's fair that I mean do you think
it's right that people have to lose
weight before they run for office or
does that display a kind of
self-discipline that we look for in
leaders
hmm
I I don't know I don't I don't I don't
think that everybody loses weight before
they run for office uh I I don't know I
I think it was just weird to see the
words reportedly and pudding yeah on the
same headline I also think I agree with
Kaylee some of it was unfair because
another thing they said that he's always
this is their words not mine that when
he's eating he's always quote getting
everywhere and that's a little ableist
because when I eat I make a mess like
yes and it's it's a fine motor issue
it's not it's not a manners issue I just
can never seem to get all the crackers
in the soup that is a problem you know
sometimes I miss yes and I would it's
like I'm sitting down like oh I want to
get all the food everywhere so people
will laugh and say ooh cat you're
disgusting I'm not making a choice yeah
it's it's a problem you're you know what
you're being slob shamed yeah no it's
it's ableist is it ableist being a slob
I think so or calling somebody a slob
yeah well I think everything is ableist
if you try hard enough that is true that
is true all right well we learned
nothing hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else